okay he pushes a pawn but this is
basically admitting that he's about to
lose his knight
it's a desperate try
so
white can now either give a check or he
could just bring his rook up as you've
advocated but okay maxim is full of
those tricks and he's not going to
die without a fight so after rook takes
yeah so now
white's king has run away black has won
the white bishop but i think black is
going to be helpless to stop a
checkmating attack against his king
white's rook can just lift itself up
it's going to be devastation on the
seventh rank right now
we've talked about it so much look at
this once you penetrate to your
opponent's seventh rank you're destined
to win the game the white queen and
white rook are going to team up and trap
the black king there's no checks for
black
and that means that maximum graph he
leans back and he resigns about to be
checkmated
wow it's over one point four minus girls
now in the blitz winning game one with
the white pieces maximum vagina will be
in a must-win situation in blitz game 2
to take it to tie breaks if he's not
able to win it magnus carlsen will be
the winner of the match sitting still by
the board magnus looking over this
and there he lives all right what a good
feeling for magnus girls and he's able
to win
the first blitz game
he did just outplay the frenchman he
slowly got his pieces into the game and
despite the fact he missed an immediate
win he still had a dominating position
and he's he kind of finished it off very
very smoothly all right
a little bit of a wig for magnus cause
i'm going back to the lounge to get
ready